the fact is the vaccine push is on and
if some companies can sort of push that
along
uh well they're all in especially what's
going on in krispy kreme right now
that institute a new policy if you can
prove you've taken at least one dose of
a vaccine they'll give you a free
doughnut
so it seemed like a perfectly good deal
to me i would just go into one krispy
kreme
after another repeatedly get thousands
of donuts with the same
proof anyway what's happening now is the
food police are going after krispy kreme
saying that
this is actually advocating unhealthy
behavior that if you eat donuts all the
time you can get that as if
uh anyway i want to get the reading all
of this from a guy who meant to do well
mike patterson is the krispy kreme ceo
very good to have you um the food police
are after you mike they don't like what
you seem to be advocating
but i i think you did also say
everything in moderation right
i i we have i mean you think about last
year
we did this thing called acts of joy you
and i chatted about this
about a year ago you know when we opened
up to the health care industry
and they could get any donut as many as
they wanted anytime
we gave away 30 million donuts last year
in the u.s
so you know when people make a choice as
america gets a hold of the pandemic and
it's a personal choice people make
you know they they look for if there's a
treat that they can get and we can serve
it
it's great i've been actually in the
shops so
i was in chicago and louisville this
week and uh when folks would show me
their cdc card and i go you want that
donut they're like yes sir
i'm uh and they're really happy and it's
just a little treat and it just shows
the generosity of the brand
we are a sweet treat brand and we get
that
yeah yeah and i i see where you're going
but you know mike i'm
people who are very creative right they
can come up with ways to
take advantage of your your good uh deed
here uh do you get a lot of customers
who go from kristin
to krispy kreme still showing that proof
of a vaccine i can't be the only one
doing that
um you know we won't make up our
programs for the folks that are going to
try to beat the system
if that's what they want to do that's
fine the generosity of the brand is what
we really stand for
um now back to the issue that uh
obesity is a far bigger issue in this
country and this was raised in the
washington boats today
and that you should be aware of that and
they're lecturing you on that because
uh however threatening you look at the
virus
uh obesity kills tens of thousands more
and that your product leads to that you
say
you know we're a pro we're a donut i'm
uh
and our brand actually serves it
primarily in dozens we're a sweet treat
um and it's shared people mostly use a
krispy kreme occasion and they share it
with their friends and
the average american visits a krispy
kreme about four times a year
so i think we're okay there in
moderation like anything else people
will always want us to retreat
um they'll make their own judgment
no i think you're right about that um i
just wanted to get your take on all of
that um because
uh you know no good deed goes unpunished
people can't push it but
i'm gonna warn americans that you really
shouldn't do what i've been doing and go
from krispy kreme to krispy kreme
because that's just
you know shop so maybe i'll find you i
mean i could tell you that you know when
i dropped off some donuts at the
vaccination centers
uh this week as well they just love it
uh they're working hard so
at least we can just help them out
well i'm getting worried right because a
lot of your stores have have photos of
me saying have you seen this man
mike pattisfield yeah have you made it
to the place the crispy cream
in new york no no i haven't been to the
flagship shop but at any way you can get
me there i'm there
so mike thank you very very much
all right thank you very much on this